おっ
こんにちは
はい今日8思いがけずこんなチャンスをいただき
行ったあとちょっとほくそ笑んでおります open the box 8今回の
テックスの作のテーマ
これを与えられた時私ここで touch と呼ばせていただきますけれども考えた
ことがあります
箱っていろいろあるよねっで私たちが考えた箱っていうのはえーっギフトボックスが
毎日自分の手元に新しいものが届いているそんなイメージですその中は
にを開ける楽しいそれを挙げた開けたいでも放送しも可愛いけど開きたい
ビルベリー不器用に開けて
何入ってるんだろうなに入ってるんだろふたを開ければでワクワクとドキドキが止まら
ない
そんな子供の頃を思い出すようなそんな箱
そんな箱が自分に毎日送られてくるそんなことをイメージしました
そして
ギフトボックスは
人から送られるものだけなのでしょうか
待っていればもしかしたらどこからああ
ギフトボックス送られてくるかもしれません
でも来ないかもしれない
そうだギフトボックスに入れるものは自分たちで選ぶことができる
自分でその中に入れておきたいものをたくさんの人が笑顔とか喜んな顔
驚いた顔そんなサプライズを入れたいそう考えました
私は小さいころ
小学校で中身はにですねまぁ池だったんですけども
休み時間ずーっとありを救っていたりとかで
菌根菌コンってなっても気付かだってで授業に出なかったりして
あきちゃ真姫ちゃん真姫ちゃんって言われてても気づかないあとは
添ええっと
鉄棒あるんですが鉄棒の味あれどんな味だけなぁであれられたらどうなるのかあぁ
みたいなことをあの算数の時間にぼーっと考えているような子でした
もちろん変則の時のバスも一番最後にぼーっとしてて乗り遅れるその前にちょっと優し
さがあってはを振れていると思う
家を呼びに行くんですけどその友達を待っていると先に行かれてしまうそんな方でした
小さい頃はまぁちょっと抜けてるけどまぁかわいいよねとかそんなところもいいよね
なんて言われてはいました
ただこれが大人になって
中学校高校なんかちょっと行きづらいな
小学生のまま自由にいろんなことをできたりちょっと抜けてたり
どうして許されないのかなって思うようになってきました
だんだん両親から
広く怒られたりなじられたり
お前なんか生まれてこなければよかったそんな風に言われることもありました
いつからか私は自分自身で自分の存在を気すっ
箱には何も入れないでおこう
そういう選択をするようになりました
そうして
35ぐらいの時にとうとう体が限界を
迎え
うつ病と珍談されました
でもそれは一時的なものでした
検査をしました
adhd
僕系とですが
右から入った情報をうまく便席する力がなかったようなのです
ちょっとホッとしました
自分が何者であるのか
自分が苦しんでいたことが何なのか少しずつ分かりました
分かってきたと同時にイ
世の中ってどうしてこうなんだろう
なんでこうできないことを無理やり近いところから埋めていくようなことしかしないん
だろう
だって得意な事があれば得意なところを
もっともっと伸ばすようにしていけば自然にこっちの穴なのか埋まるようになるじゃん
そう考えるようになりました
まだまだ力不足の私なので
ギフトボックスを埋めるために何を入れればいいのか正直まだわかっていません
ただ今
メンタルクリニックでジム件
受付と後患者様の小さな相談にも乗らせていただいています
かけていること木
そこにフォーカスするんではなくて
得意な事を伸ばすようにして楽しんでいれば穴っていつが埋まる
ケースの中には笑顔とワクワクとドキドキがいっぱい入っている
そんな風に
そんな箱
作っていけたらなと思っていますありがとうございます